okay I've got a 2020 Civic SI here and I
tried to use the physical key in the
door like
such and
realized it doesn't do anything and I
read on the Civic X
forms that sometimes these vehicles
leave the factory with uh the door or
rather the loock linkage disconnected so
I'm going to show you how to reconnect
this linkage uh the forms made it seem
like you had to take the door panel off
uh I don't believe you do so I'm going
to walk you guys through it all you're
going to need for this is some kind of
plastic pry tool maybe even your
fingernails uh if your nails are long
enough we just have to get a plastic
cover off and then I also have a ratchet
here with an extension uh and a 10 mm
socket this a/ quar inch ratchet but use
whatever you have here you don't need
this long of an extension but uh it'll
do let's go
first thing you're going to do is locate
your door pop it open get to this little
access uh panel here going to take our
tool and try to get under this just
enough to kind of pop it up and I think
I got most of it there come
on let's try this there we go and this
is going to reveal a 10 mm bolt that
holds the whole door handle assembly on
uh so we're going to remove this
next okay 10 mm on here make sure not to
drop this bolt I'm going to put down the
camera so I can uh make sure to do
that okay my little bolt is out and now
we should be able to remove this the
handle's going to stay in place a little
bit what we're going to try to do is
just get up behind uh the lock cylinder
and there is a tab that holds these two
together um so we kind of have to do it
like this
this one handed there we go so we got
the lock out and you can see this is the
long shaft with this kind of almost
Phillips looking cross uh style thing
that engages into the door panel um and
allows you to unlock the door um this is
going to stay here just got to align
this gasket uh right when we put it back
together so I'm trying to get you guys a
shot of the part of the door panel that
it engages with um and you can see it
right there when I looked at mine
through the side of the door through
that little access Hole uh I could tell
it was not even in line with that hole
and it was just flopping around so what
we're going to do now is try our best to
realign that back into the hole uh
probably probably will take a few times
to get that right um and I'll report
back after I got it back
in another quick note is if the door uh
handle starts to come off just slide it
back in this direction it has to lock in
uh on this side and then it'll see there
we go I have to slide this a little more
and it'll uh behave like normal uh so
what we're going to do is put this fella
back in there note the tab right here
that has to go behind uh the door
handle okay I've got it back on there
door handle is slid back to the left
this is back on um and I actually got
this one on the first try you kind of
see the shaft through there but I'm not
going to be able to get a good image uh
of anything but um I got it in first try
if I put the key in
now you'll hear the door locks click
we're good to go what we'll do is we'll
uh tighten that 10 mm back down and make
sure my gasket is all aligned you can
see this one's a little screwed up right
now so I'll see if I can get it back in
a good
State all right just put that bolt back
in door handle looking good going to put
this cap back in
there good to go now just as expected I
suggest everybody try this you know with
their emergency key make sure it can
unlock and lock your doors um because if
it can't and your key fob battery dies
uh you won't be able to get into the car
and you'd rather find this out and fix
it now then have to deal with that uh
you know when you're stranded somewhere
and your key fob is dead um so thanks
for watching guys hope this helped
thanks quick bonus tip for you guys if
you hit the unlock button and then hold
the unlock button it'll roll down all
the windows as well as the sunroof um
and with the key fob I don't believe
there's a way to undo this and roll back
up the windows so now that your lock
works again uh what you can do you put
it in here bring it to the right
once hold it in this position and the
windows will start to roll back up and
you just got to hold it there as a
safety feature until they're all back
and rolled
up pretty neat feature especially in the
summer